[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen an diesem
Sonntagabend das Wichtigste vom Sport
das erfahren Sie gleich von Norbert
König ja guten Abend und wir blicken
unter anderem auf diese Themen heute
weniger EU mehr Nationalstaat im ZDF
sommerinterview fordert afd-chef krupala
eine Neuausrichtung der Politik
es ist noch nicht überstanden nach den
schweren Regenfällen in Slowenien drohen
weitere Erdrutsche zwei Drittel des
Landes sind betroffen
und knapper geht nicht bei der Frauen WM
fliegt der entscheidende Elfmeter gerade
so über die Linie die Schwedinnen sind
im Viertelfinale und die USA raus
die AFD sieht die Europäische Union als
gescheitertes Projekt und will eine
Neugründung als sogenannter Bund
europäischer Nationen das hat die Partei
als Ziel für die Europawahl beschlossen
bei ihrem Parteitag in Magdeburg an
diesem Wochenende
koopertal-chef Propeller war jetzt im
zdf-sommer Interview Nicol Diekmann
berichtet
die AFD sei keine reine Protestpartei
sondern auch programmpartei darauf legt
ihr
koffersitzenderpropeller Wert auch im
Sommer Interview gleichzeitig aber räumt
er im ZDF ein ausschließlich der eigenen
Stärke verdankt die AFD ihren Umfrage
Höhenflug nicht natürlich profitieren
wir auch von den Fehlern der anderen das
war immer die Aufgabe der Opposition
Opposition heißt Kontrolle das ist die
Aufgabe der Opposition das nehmen wir
wahr zehn Jahre nach ihrer Gründung
träumt die AFD von
Regierungsbeteiligungen in Bund und
Ländern und wird für sich mit ihrem
Kernthema Abschottung zur Bekämpfung des
Fachkräftemangels etwa setzt die in
Teilen rechtsextreme Parteien nicht
Stefan Fachleuten empfohlen auf
Zuwanderung sondern auf eher
langfristige Lösungen
wir haben eine de facto ein Kind Politik
da müssen wir ansetzen damit wir in 20
30 Jahren entweder aus eigener Kraft
heraus und das musste Anspruch einer
Industrienation wie Deutschland mit 84
Millionen Einwohnern sein aus eigener
Kraft heraus mit unserem Nachwuchs auch
wieder die Fachbegriffe generieren
können auch Fundamentalkritik an der EU
gehört zu DNA der AFD ihr Parteichef
fordert einen Rückbau wir wollen wieder
nationale Entscheidung dahin verlagern
wo sie hingehören und das sind die
nationalen Parlamente ist der Deutsche
Bundestag es kann nicht sein dass 70 80
Prozent der Gesetzgebungen in Brüssel
entschieden werden und wir im Prinzip in
Berlin nur noch die Kammer sind für
diese unsäglichen Gesetze ein Rückbau
der EU eine radikale Forderung eine noch
radikalere nämlich die komplette
Auflösung der EU hat die AFD heute auf
ihrem europawahlparteitag in Magdeburg
aus ihrem Programm gestrichen
Thomas Reichert ist die AFD also
tatsächlich von ihrer Forderung nach
einer Auflösung der EU abgerückt wie
schätzen Sie das ein
ja da ist in die AFD in der Tat davon
zurückgerudert statt der Auflösung will
sie nun die Transformation der EU das
ist vor allem eine sprachliche
Abschwächung weniger eine inhaltliche
auf diesem Parteitag der vor etwa zwei
Stunden zu Ende ging haben sich delete
darin zu übertreffen versucht die EU
immer noch drastischer zu kritisieren da
war etwa die Rede von einem Monster die
man die Tentakeln abschlagen müssen im
Programm klingt das nun etwas milder die
AFD legt also ein bisschen Zuckerguss
über einen unverändert harten Kern
tatsächlich will die Partei in Europa
die Uhr zurückdrehen will ein Ende des
Euro und ein Ende des EU-Parlaments
zusammenarbeiten soll Europa aus AFD
sich gerade noch bei der Abwehr von
Flüchtling auffallend auch die AFD
wendet sich wenn überhaupt nur sehr sehr
leise gegen Putins Angriff wie laut ist
da die Kritik an den USA das Programm
ist also nicht nur Anti EU sondern auch
stramm an die westlich die AFD glaubt
dass Deutschland in einer
unübersichtlichen Welt am besten zurecht
kommt wenn es von Verbündeten
verabschiedet und auf sich selbst
zurückzieht
und das gesamte ZDF soll mal Interview
mit afd-chef Tino krupala können Sie
direkt nach dieser Sendung sehen
gerade kam die Nachricht dass sich die
Fraktionschefin der Linken im Bundestag
am Mira Mohammed Ali von ihrem Amt
zurückzieht sie werde bei der kommenden
Vorstandswahl Anfang September nicht
mehr kandidieren so Mohammed Ali laut
dpa die sind Scheidung habe politische
Gründe den letzten Ausschlag habe die
Distanzierung der Parteispitze von Sarah
Wagenknecht Anfang Juni gegeben fragen
wir nach bei Carl Hinterleitner Karl was
bedeutet das jetzt für die Linkspartei
hier Spannung in der Linken gibt es ja
schon lange jetzt haben sie sich
entladen und alles entzündet sich an der
Frage wie umgehen mit Sarah Wagenknecht
die hätte die Gründung einer eigenen
Partei mehrfach angekündigt also der
maximale Erfahrung gegen die Partei in
der sie ja eigentlich ist darüber nach
der Parteivorstand beschlossen sie
aufzufordern die Fraktion zu verlassen
und gesagt Wagenknecht habe in der
Linken keine Zukunft mehr dagegen wendet
sich jetzt die Fraktionsvorsitzende die
sagt das kam eben rein wörtliches gäbe
den permanentenversuch der Parteispitze
Situation ihren Kurs aufzuzwingen dieser
Kurs beschleunige die Niedergang der
Linken wenn das die Fraktionsvorsitzende
vom Vorstand sagt dann ist aus den
Spannungen schon so ein Art Spaltung
geworden und das Entscheidende ist jetzt
wie sich andere Fraktionsmitglieder
verhalten denn wenn drei Mitglieder der
Fraktion gehen würden dann verloren die
Linke ihren Status als Fraktion hätte
dann kaum noch rederechte hätte
erhebliche finanzielle Einbußen könnte
nicht mehr Ausschüssen mitarbeiten mit
anderen Worten es wäre gar keine
effektive Oppositionsarbeit mehr möglich
wenn das passieren würde dann wäre das
der Anfang vom Ende der Linken als ernst
zu nehmende Kraft danke für diese
Einordnung
zu den Unwettern in Slowenien es sei die
schlimmste Naturkatastrophe der letzten
30 Jahre so die Regierung nachdem
Dauerregen und den Überschwemmungen
wächst jetzt die Gefahr weiterer
Erdrutsche in Österreich ist vor allem
der Süden betroffen in Slowenien sind es
zwei Drittel des Landes im Osten brach
am Fluss nur ein Darm hunderte Menschen
wurden in Sicherheit gebracht mehrere
Orte sein gefährdet wie auch am
Flüsschen Micha Wolf Christian Ulrich
hier im Tal der maisha sind einige
Katastrophenopfer nur mit dem
Hubschrauber erreichbar die Polizei
bringt Trinkwasser aus der Luft der
kleine Industrie-
der Fluss hat alles mitgerissen mehr als
200 Häuser sind hier untergegangen
im ganzen Land Bilder der Verwüstung und
alle packen heute mit an um wieder
aufzuräumen die Verzweiflung ist groß
einige haben in wenigen Stunden alles
verloren
wir kehren jetzt alles raus wenn man
sieht wie unser Haus jetzt aussieht
bricht man in Tränen aus
bei uns sind fünf Häuser Weg andere
stehen kurz vor dem Zusammenbruch wir
haben hier 9 Familien denen wir jetzt
helfen müssen
der Schock sitzt tief ins Slowenien man
geht von Schäden in Milliardenhöhe aus
die EU hat Hilfe versprochen die
Staatspräsidentin appelliert an den
Zusammenhalt
lasst uns das zusammen ertragen lasst
uns jetzt zusammen stehen die Lage ist
so schlimm dass es nicht über Nacht
besser wird aber am Ende werden wir es
überstehen
auch im Süden Österreichs wie hier in
Kärnten hat das Wasser die Hänge so
aufgeweicht dass viele Orts Erdrutsche
abgehen und dabei Häuser zerstören
Albtraum für die Bewohner
das ist mein Platz hier bin ich
aufgewachsen
sorge bereitet nun der hohe Pegelstand
der Mur flussabwärts ins Slowenien und
Kroatien sind mehrere Dörfer evakuiert
hier betet man dass es nicht schlimmer
wird
wieder dramatische Szenen vor der
italienischen Insel Lampedusa zwei
Flüchtlingsboote waren in Seenot geraten
53 Schiffbrüchige hat die Küstenwache
gerettet 30 weitere werden noch vermisst
eine andere Gruppe flüchtete sich auf
einen Felsen und wurde per Hubschrauber
an Land geholt die insgesamt 500
Menschen werden nun nach und nach ans
Festland gebracht
in Lissabon hat Papst franziskus mit
Gläubigen aus allen erteilen den
Abschlussgottesdienst des
Weltjugendtages gefeiert mehr als einer
Million Menschen rief der 86-Jährige zu
Nürtingen
fürchtet euch nicht er als alter Mann
träume von einer Jugend die den Frieden
lebt und den Frieden aufbaut
abschließend gab franziskus den Ort des
nächsten weltjugendtreffens bekannt die
südkoreanische Hauptstadt zool
ja bei der Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft gab
es ja jetzt schon die nächste
Überraschung die Titelverteidigung sind
draußen noch und zwar in einem Krimi der
es nach der Verlängerung so richtig
Fahrt aufnimmt und der das Happy End für
die Schwedinnen bereithält die gewinnen
das Elfmeterschießen gegen den
viermaligen Weltmeister USA mit einer
wahrhaften Millimeter Entscheidung
in der regulären Spielzeit die USA mit
den besseren Chancen auch im
Elfmeterschießen zunächst dem Vorteil
mit dem Fehlschuss von Meghan rapino
nimmt das amerikanische Drama aber
seinen Lauf der Star des US-Teams
verschießt genauso wieder nach Sophias
Mist die ihre Mannschaft mit diesem
Elfmeter ins Viertelfinale hätte
schießen können kurz darauf hat Lina
hurtig als 14 Schütze in den Sieg für
Schweden auf dem Fuß der Ball abgewehrt
nachdem er unbestritten und offiziell
bestätigt hinter der Linie war Schweden
ist weiter trifft am Freitag auf Japan
einen Favoritinnen Sieg gab es im ersten
Spiel des Tages die Auswahl der
Niederlande gewinnt mit 2:0 gegen das
Team aus Südafrika und spielt im
Viertelfinale gegen Spanien bei der
radwm in Glasgow hat sich matjö van der
Pool trotz eines Sturzes den Titel im
Straßenrennen der Männer geholt van der
Pool triumphiert nach gelungenem
Ausreißversuch und ist damit der erste
niederländische Weltmeister seit 38
Jahren gut eineinhalb Minuten dahinter
der Belgier wirkt von Art den Sprint um
Bronze sichert sich der Slowene Tadday
pogaccia rechts im Bild im Duell mit dem
Dänen Petersen
die ausnahmeturnerin Simon Beils hat
nach zwei Jahren Wettkampfpause ein
beeindruckendes Comeback gegeben bei den
US Classics in Chicago gewinnt die
US-Amerikanerin den meerkampf und zwei
Geräte Finals bei den Olympischen
Spielen 2021 war die jetzt 26-Jährige
mit psychischen Problemen ausgestiegen
auch bedingt durch die Aufdeckung des
Missbrauchs Skandals um den ehemaligen
US-Team Arzt Larry
ein wirklich besonders erfreuliches
Comeback das stimmt
noch auf die Wetteraussichten
am Vormittag gibt es noch Schauer und
Gewitter zum Nachmittag kommt von Westen
mehr und mehr die Sonne hervor es ist
windig an den Küsten gibt es Sturm die
Temperatur erreicht 14 bis 21 Grad
das heute journal können Sie um 21.45
sehen mit Christian Sievers morgen steht
hier mit riserin